it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skincare nerd
and massive sunscreen nerd and today we
are talking about zinc oxide sunscreens
there are so many myths around mineral or
physical sunscreens these are the ones with
zinc oxide and titanium dioxide and how they're
supposedly better than chemical sunscreens
these are the ones with scarier sounding
names like oxybenzone and octocrylene
and it's usually zinc oxide
that gets all of the hype
some of these advantages are
true but so many are just myths
and a lot of these myths are being
spread on social media not just by
influencers but by sunscreen brands doctors
dermatologists cosmetic scientists and i think
these myths are getting people to use sunscreens
that aren't necessarily the best option for them
i've talked about the pros and cons of
chemical and physical sunscreens before
with things like safety and
irritation and environmental impact
you can check out my other videos on those but
today i wanted to focus on the myth that zinc
oxide sunscreens are actually better sunscreens
that they give better protection against uv
i was originally going to cover
the other myths as well but then
this video ended up way too long so that is
future michelle's problem i've also probably
missed a few myths so if you can think
of any more leave them in the comments
if you like sciency beauty
content click the like and
the subscribe and the nerdification
bell so you don't miss any videos
first off i have nothing against people using
zinc oxide sunscreens if you prefer them then
keep using them i just want everyone to
know the real benefits and drawbacks so
that you can make the best decision for your
own situation i'm going to be calling the two
types of sunscreen chemical and physical
in this video it's not great terminology
and it kills me a bit inside every time i use it
organic and inorganic are far more accurate but
chemical and physical is what everyone calls
them so i'm just going to be a sheep here
zinc oxide and titanium dioxide are physical
sunscreens everything else is chemical
so zinc oxide being the most effective sunscreen
the most common reason i've seen for this is
the myth that zinc oxide works like a shield
it reflects and scatters uv while chemical
sunscreens work like a sponge they absorb uv
this is probably the most widespread myth about
chemical and physical sunscreens and it's not true
just like chemical sunscreens mineral
sunscreens mostly work by absorbing uv
and turning it into a tiny amount of heat about
95 of the uv that hits a mineral sunscreen gets
absorbed and turned into heat only about
five percent gets scattered if you want
to learn more about the nitty-gritty details
of how sunscreens work i have a video on that
i'm not sure why scattering is used to make
mineral sunscreen sound better i think it's to do
with how absorbing sounds bad like it's not really
getting rid of the uv and it's not as good as like
a superhero shield that darts around and bounces
off the uv i think it's also confusion around
the word absorb because it sounds like chemical
sunscreens absorb into the skin and that means
that it's not really protecting the upper layers
which is also a myth but it doesn't really matter
because almost all of the uv is absorbed by the
mineral sunscreen only a tiny amount is scattered
now some people might cling onto that scattered
five percent and still say that because of that
zinc oxide is better but scattering isn't
actually as good as it sounds most of the
scattered uv is actually scattered forward so
deeper towards your skin this isn't really a
problem because it increases the chance of that
uv hitting another sunscreen particle and getting
absorbed but basically absorption is actually
really good because it destroys the uv and
turns it into something less harmful whereas
scattering just sort of deflects the bullet
now this myth birthed another myth maybe we can
start making like a sunscreen myth family tree
a cursed family tree mineral sunscreens
are better because they don't produce heat
well i've already said that there's only a five
percent difference in heat and five percent is
tiny but zinc loyalists might say that five
percent still might matter that heat still
might contribute to pigment and melasma so i did
a test with a thermal camera and some sunscreens
and it turns out that the difference in heat is
undetectable the difference is actually smaller
than the difference in heat between this
part of your arm and this part of your arm
there's also the idea that mineral
sunscreen specifically zinc oxide
is broader spectrum and so it protects against
more uv wavelengths unlike chemical sunscreens
again this is probably like a cousin of
the shield thing but it is partly true zinc
oxide is a broader spectrum ingredient
it protects against uva1 uva2 and uvb
but not because it works like a shield
titanium dioxide is also a mineral sunscreen
but it isn't very good at protecting against the
longer wavelengths of uva 1 unless it starts going
white and there are chemical sunscreens that
can protect against all three regions as well
but i guess it boils down to does a broader
spectrum sunscreen ingredient lead to
a more protective sunscreen well no broad spectrum
just tells you about the breadth of protection and
not the strength of protection and the strength of
protection is where zinc oxide really falls short
sunscreen protection is a bit like a wall zinc
oxide is a broad spectrum ingredient so it's
like a really wide wall it protects against all
the wavelengths but it's not a very protective
strong wall it's a bit like swiss cheese it's got
lots of holes so if you only have one layer of
this rather holey wall then you can still get lots
of uv getting through you can imagine uv as like
balls getting thrown against this wall a
lot of balls will still go through the wall
chemical sunscreens are like narrow
walls without a lot of breath so they
only protect a small section but they tend
to be stronger so they have less gaps and
so they protect a small section but they
protect that small section a bit better
so right now it seems like both options aren't
great but we can improve both of them we can
stack more of these zinc oxide walls together
and so you end up with a lot more protection
all along the wall this is the equivalent
of adding more zinc oxide to the sunscreen
different chemical sunscreens protect
against different parts of the uv
spectrum and so we can put up
more walls on different places
we're mixing different chemical sunscreen
ingredients into the one sunscreen product
now the problem is we can't just jam in an
infinite amount of zinc oxide into a sunscreen
we need other things in the sunscreen product
to help it spread out to keep it on the skin
to stop it from feeling and looking like chalk
chemical sunscreens are soluble so they feel a
lot better than zinc oxide and it turns out
we can mix more chemical ingredients into
a sunscreen to get a higher protection than we
can get if we just jam zinc oxide into a product
there's been some new developments in zinc
oxide technology where you can basically
get different shapes of zinc oxide
particles to get higher protection
but still the maximum you can get from a zinc
oxide only sunscreen is still around spf 60 and
uvapf 20 with chemical sunscreens you can
get spfs of over 100 and uvapfs of over 60
if you look at the highest spf rated
sunscreens none of them use zinc
oxide they all have a mixture of chemical filters
and titanium dioxide or just chemical filters
which is another funny part of this titanium
dioxide is actually a really efficient sunscreen
ingredient it gives much stronger protection
than zinc oxide and a lot of chemical sunscreen
ingredients as well but poor titanium dioxide
gets ignored because i don't know zinc oxides
the golden child but the metal oxides still
doesn't protect really well in the uva1
region so if you want a high uva1 sunscreen
then you kind of have to go with chemical
so the whole zinc oxide is the only fda approved
ingredient that protects against uva 1 uva 2
and uvb it doesn't make zinc oxide sunscreens
more protective because you can mix different
chemical ingredients into the one sunscreen
and that means it can block uva 1 uva 2 and uvb
it's like saying salt tastes good on its
own so plain salted food is the tastiest
well no because you can mix
other seasonings together
there's also the myth that zinc oxide protects
against blue light and again it's more of that
zinc oxide is like a shield that protects
against everything for a sunscreen against
visible light you need iron oxides and pigmentary
titanium dioxide which has large particles and
looks white iron oxides absorb visible light
pigmentary titanium dioxide scatters light so
it bounces it around the sunscreen film until it
has a chance to be absorbed by the iron oxides
again absorption is the bomb i don't
know if people still say the bomb
tinted products like foundations
tinted moisturizers tinted sunscreens
usually have both pigmentary titanium
dioxide and iron oxides so they give
the best protection mineral sunscreens don't
absorb visible light and they don't scatter
visible light unless it's accidental
white cast is what happens when you
have scattering but mineral sunscreen ingredients
are optimized to try to minimize that white cast
there is one study from colorescience where
the conclusion claims that zinc oxide makes
titanium dioxide and iron oxides work better
but the data they show doesn't really support
this they test with four products
three tinted sunscreens and one face
cream the formula with the least mineral
sunscreen ingredients and the lowest spf
actually gave the best visible light
protection so yeah keep in mind that
you can't necessarily trust the conclusions
of studies you need to read them critically
zinc oxide is better because it works immediately
this one's a bit weird and i think it's another
bastard child of the reflect versus absorb myth
i think people got confused between absorbing
uv and absorbing into skin you might have seen
this as chemical sunscreens need to absorb or
react with skin to work and so you have to apply
chemical sunscreens 15 minutes before you go out
into the sun whereas physical sunscreens work
immediately these are all myths both types of
sunscreen ingredients absorb uv straight away
you can see them absorbing uv on paper here but
both tyres also need about 15 minutes to spread
out on your skin to form an even intact layer so
you use them the exact same way unless it's
a special formula that's designed to absorb
into the skin like the evy sunscreens
but that's a completely separate issue
because it's more photostable and therefore
you don't need to reapply another reason
people give for zinc oxide being better is
that it's more photostable which means it
doesn't break down in the sun after absorbing
too much uv whereas chemical sunscreens do
now some chemical sunscreens can break down in the
sun and once they've broken down they don't work
as well but there are a lot of chemical sunscreen
ingredients that are photostable this includes
most of the older sunscreen filters plus the newer
sunscreen filters that were specifically designed
to be photostable and even the less photostable
chemical sunscreens can be stabilized by other
things in the formula so for example avobenzone
is pretty unstable on its own but in neutrogena's
helioplex formulas it still gives more than
85% uva protection after five hours of midday
sun exposure for all sunscreens chemical and
physical you're meant to reapply every two hours
and that's because the sunscreen layer starts to
crack and wear off sort of like how a foundation
breaks up over time so five hours from helioplex
should be more than enough there's a study that
looked at how well different sunscreens absorbed
uv after leaving them in uv for a while the higher
the line is the more it's protecting in that
region the top two sunscreens have avobenzone
the bottom one has zinc oxide and titanium dioxide
only you can see that none of them are changing
too much after uv exposure you can compare that
with a non-photostable sunscreen like this one
now there are some arguments why zinc oxide can
actually be less protective even with the same spf
reason number one is people are likely to apply
less zinc oxide sunscreens zinc oxide sunscreens
have a lot of drawbacks that are pretty obvious if
you've ever tried them they can leave a white cast
especially if you have darker skin and sometimes
it fades away but a lot of the time it doesn't and
so you end up walking around looking like you're
wearing youtuber makeup they usually have a pretty
thick texture zinc oxide is an insoluble mineral
and so texture wise it's a lot like ground up dirt
or rock it's not great at absorbing uv so a lot of
the time in sunscreens you need 10 to 25 percent
so you can imagine if you have like a jar of
moisturizer you're adding one to two and a
half teaspoons of dirt into this the base of the
sunscreen also has to be pretty thick to keep the
particles suspended and spread out and not let
them sink to the bottom for a relatively long
period of time so it's not a great setup for a
product that feels nice on your skin and they
tend to clog up pores as well they're also usually
pretty drying because zinc oxide can soak up oil
a bit like a clay mask on the other hand chemical
sunscreens tend to be a lot lighter not always but
it's a lot more doable and they tend not to have a
white cast now all of this might seem superficial
and not a big deal but cosmetic elegance is
important a little doesn't go a long way with
sunscreens for a sunscreen to work you need to
be applying the right amount which is quite a lot
and reapplying it often and you're less likely
to do that with a sunscreen that's super white
and super thick a cerave survey found that 55
percent of people who skipped daily sunscreen
did this because they didn't like the
way it feels during and after application
38% said that white cast was an issue there's also
a study from a sunscreen ingredient manufacturer
so flagging for possible bias but they make
both organic and inorganic sunscreen ingredients
they found that people unconsciously used 29%
less of a 6% titanium dioxide sunscreen versus
a sunscreen that had 3% titanium dioxide
and 3% of a chemical sunscreen ingredient
you can also see a lot of reviews of zinc
oxide sunscreens online where they say
it's really thick but a little goes
a long way which just doesn't work
the other big issue we don't really talk about
much with mineral sunscreens is stability and
not photostability but just regular stability for
a sunscreen to work well the sunscreen ingredients
have to stay spread out in the sunscreen in
the bottle during its lifetime plus when you're
applying it on your skin plus when it's been
sitting on your skin for a while if it clumps
up then you get holes in your protection most
chemical sunscreens are soluble which means it's
mixed at a molecular level it's a little bit like
vinegar when you have vinegar the vinegar molecule
stays spread out in the vinegar for a really long
time they don't eventually sink to the bottom but
when you have bigger particles it's a lot harder
to keep them separated for longer you can use
a thicker texture with rheology modifiers to
keep the particles further apart for longer
you can also coat the particles to try to
stop them from clumping but at the end of
the day particles are always going to be harder
to stabilize than a solution or a normal emulsion
this is especially the case when you have zinc
oxide and titanium dioxide they are really dense
materials four to six times denser than water and
so gravity wants to pull them to the bottom and
it's even worse when you have uncoated zinc oxide
which a lot of natural sunscreen companies tend
to use because the coatings tend to be synthetic
zinc oxide itself is already pretty synthetic but
they just don't use them these uncoated
particles really want to clump up a lot
so these large particles tend to clump up together
and separate in the bottle if you leave it for too
long if you let it get too hot or if you apply it
to your skin and let it get wet and i think this
is the reason why a lot of mineral sunscreens
especially those from natural brands that use
uncoated zinc oxide in a really oily base tend to
get really bad scores in consumer reports tests
they measure the spf after something that's
pretty similar to the water resistance test
they apply the sunscreen to the person they get
the person to sit in water and then they test the
spf and there are also lots of reviews of these
sorts of products from people who got burnt while
using them and i think it's a mixture of people
being more likely to under apply a really thick
product and just the unstable drama queen nature
of uncoated zinc oxide but i think if you're
aware of these issues then it's fine because
you can work around them make sure you still
apply the right amount of sunscreen don't use it
if it's expired don't let the bottle get too hot
don't use it if it's separated so at the end of
the day is the same thing that i keep on saying
the best sunscreen is the one that you use if
it's something you enjoy if it's something that
fits in your budget if it's something that you
can easily access if it's something that doesn't
irritate your skin then it's going to be the best
sunscreen for you it doesn't really matter if it's
physical or chemical and also remember sunscreen
is not the be-all and end-all you can also use
other sun protective measures like hats and
clothing so hopefully i've covered most of the
myths about zinc oxide being more protective if
i didn't leave me a comment with the extra myths
if you liked the video click the like and the
subscribe you can also follow me on instagram
and check out my blog see you next time hopefully
it's not about sunscreen again but i can't make
any promises because it is heading to sunscreen
season and you are going to see myths everywhere